all righty just wind it up here okay
this is from sorry if I'm saying your
name incorrectly a Gabor Rosa hello good
good boy when the movie is done how can
you reach the audience what's the
marketing strategy how do you
communicate with the crowd successfully
oh the next question that's a great
question I have a lot to say about this
okay um well I think that okay and I
want to get to whatever here but okay so
I think that like my marketing strategy
has basically been like I want to build
up a big email list of people that I can
then sell the movie directly to when we
do a digital release later this year
that's been my marketing strategy and
the reason why it's it's like email as
opposed to you know Facebook or Twitter
and things like that is because like the
reality is that like when we when we
think of like what a platform is a
platform is basically a way where you
can where you can reach the people that
you need to reach in a way that usually
is cost-effective and just effective
like in terms of getting someone's
attention and then getting them to do
something right and the issue at least
for for me with like social media and
things like that is I think sometimes
people think that those are platforms
but they're they're really not though
and the reason why I don't think that
those are platforms is because it's like
very very like for instance like with
with Facebook you know they're
constantly tweaking their algorithm
right and so like you know we've got
we've got a few thousand followers for
then there was Joe we've got 12,000
followers for them there was Joe on
Instagram but like such a very small
percentage of those people actually see
anything I post and that's because of an
algorithm an algorithm that's like okay
well we can't just post that and then
BOOM 12,000 people see it and I think a
lot of people think that's how it were
but that's not how it works and so to me
if I have 12,000 people that have
expressed interest and like I really
like that but I can't reach them then
that's not an effective tool to get
their attention and get them to do
something so for me my my strategy is to
yeah is to build up an email list and
because the great part of our email is
email is decentralized like it's not no
one owns email you know it's like email
is like an older technology but from a
time period we're like the web was more
open than it is now you know because you
know and and the great part about like
an email list or something because like
if Facebook ever goes under or Instagram
ever goes under which history says they
probably will it could be 20 years from
now it could be 30 years from now but
guarantee you at some point people are
gonna get tired of Instagram and there's
gonna be a new thing they're gonna move
on to that thing right I can't take
those people with me to this new thing
right but email you can take anywhere
and it's something that you if you build
up an email list you own that list
that's something you could take anywhere
and that's empowering and email has the
highest engagement across any sort of on
the entire internet email has the
highest engagement more than Facebook
more than Twitter all these different
things and so that that is my strategy
build an email list so directly to those
people and I've I've done little small
experiments and it's like phenomenal
it's incredible right so like the you
know my premiere that we had in in
Arkansas for the with the Arkansas
cinema Society with Jeff Nichols we we
sold out that premiere with one email oh
wow I literally sent one emails like hey
guys just want let you know our tickets
are available you can get them right
here thank you so much see at the show
sold out Wow
pretty incredible how many seats 315
seats Wow
just sold him out like that it was
pretty amazing it was pretty cool
like with with that email we sold almost
the entire theater and then like a day
later it was sold out
was pretty amazing and like that's that
I think is like if I were to just update
my facebook status that wouldn't happen
it probably wouldn't happen to that
degree you know what I mean
and also like to it stuff like with
these social media platforms like when
you post something you don't really know
who sees it like there's no way of
there's hardly a way to like you know
people can like it and you can see who
likes it but people seeing it there's no
you don't really have access to that
data you know so it's been that's my
that's that's my strategy it's very
simple but just build up an email list
sell the movie to those people and
there's there's tons of examples of this
working like in publishing right so like
in book publishing that's like kind of
the book publishing model is like a lot
of these authors that already have
massive email subscribers massive email
lists those are the ones that usually
get book deals it's not the other way
around
because now like a lot of these big
traditional companies they look for
people who have already built audiences
up and then they they go like hey do you
want to do something together and I
think and a lot of times we look at
these things and they because they used
to operate another way he used to
operate like oh that person has talent
cool let's do that well you know we'll
we'll create a band and then boom
they're huge you know I mean but now
it's kind of the other way around it's
like they look and see who's already
huge and they're like okay cool we can
take them and put them to the next level
you know and so I think that audience
building crowd building whatever sort of
building that you know whatever we want
to call it these days I think like in
many ways I think it's the future in a
lot of ways like to gather your own
crowd that you can talk to in a way that
is cost-effective and extremely
effective in terms of getting someone's
a 10
and being able to gather all the people
around you that are like-minded in the
sense of like they like your work I
think that's really powerful and I think
that the the world is only going to move
further in that direction over time it's
gonna be the people who successfully
build their audiences in a way that like
those people very much pay attention to
them you know and like and for some
people that's that's not that's not
email but you know there's some people
who you know if you're a Kevin Hart
you've got 40 something million people
on Instagram or so or something it's
like you're gonna reach a pretty huge
chunk of those people when did you start
building your email lists and how yeah
so I started building my email list
about a little over a year ago and like
I've learned it's very difficult to get
people's email addresses for them to
willingly give them to you cuz that's
the that's the magic like they have to
be like yes I opted in to this thing and
you know it's been a really slow process
but we've we've gathered a decent amount
considering how many people we have on
like social media and stuff like that
like we have about fifteen hundred
people or email lists now which is like
okay you know it's just hard to get
emails sorry it is yeah it is hard yeah
it's super it's super tough but like I I
think that there are ways that there are
definitely ways to accelerate that
process that I haven't explored yet that
I play and explore over the next year or
so but it so far it's been it's been
like super effective and way more so
than then getting likes on Facebook or
anything like that I'm not saying that
doesn't have any value but like I have
been able to to you to lot to actually
galvanize my my audience by people more
through that channel through email than
I have through any other channel
and what email program do you use I use
MailChimp okay yeah just super simple
and like I also try to like make my
emails seem like they're just written by
a guy like a just a dude
you know like Pollyanna sweatpants you
know because we can torito's right it's
like probably needs to reapply this
deodorant you know like that's how I try
to talk to people you know because like
I think when you get something when you
get something that's like looks like an
official newsletter I think sometimes
people can be like oh it's just from a
thing but like I for me I like when I
think of like I try to imagine it of
like what would it what would I like how
would I like to be talked to if like my
favorite creator was talking to me you
know like if let's say like Charlie
Chaplin was sending emails like how
would I want him to send an email to me
and it'd be like I wanted to just be
like a regular guy like hey I've made
this thing and you know I trip over some
stuff and you'll like it you know that's
how I would want him to talk to me so
I'd tried it that's how I try to talk to
people just like there's a dude and they
made something hopefully you like it
you